mes chers amis
mes chers amis je voudrais je voudrais
en votre nom à tous salué le président
des républicains et le président du
conseil national cheikh nicolas cher
jean pierre merci de nous avoir permis
de prendre la parole nous sommes tous
ici engagés dans des combats
ça veut dire homérique des combat
épuisant des combats qui sont aussi
exaltant parce que ben a triomphé à
vaincre sans péril on triomphe sans
gloire
et en tout cas nous si nous triomphons
le 6 et 13 décembre
là bas ce sera pas sans péril et
j'espère ce sera avec la gloire alors le
premier tour des élections régionales
c'est dans un mois vous l'ignorez pas il
nous reste un mois pour mobiliser il
nous reste un mois pour convaincre et il
ya au moins trois bonnes raisons de
faire de cette élection un grand moment
pour notre famille politique
la première c'est que cette élection
c'est le dernier grand rendez vous
électoral avec les présidentielles et
vous connaissez le slogan de la coupe du
monde de 98 et un et deux et trois zéro
et 1 c'était les municipales et de
c'était les départementales et 3 ce sera
aller et j'ajoute que nous on va même
inventé un nouveau slogan et un et deux
et trois et 4 0
la deuxième bonne raison d'aller voter
et de mobiliser largement autour de vous
c'est de dire non au cynisme absolu des
socialistes cynisme absolu
voyant qu'ils sont complètement désavoué
par les français le gouvernement cherche
par tous les moyens à faire monter le
front national bat pas pour gagner eux
mais pour nous faire perdre pour nous
voler notre victoire
alors oui il va falloir aller voter en
masse pour dire non à cette manoeuvre
honteuse et dangereuse pour l'avenir de
la france
il ya enfin une troisième bonne raison
d'aller voter et de faire voter cette
raison c'est que les régions sont des
territoires qui compte
moi j'ai tiré un peu les enseignements
du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy quand
nous étions au gouvernement et c'est
vrai que pendant que nous essayons de
réformer la france
il y avait des contre-pouvoirs qui
bloquait et ses contre-pouvoirs qui
bloquait c'est et les régions
socialistes quand on lançait un plan
alzheimer
il aurait fallu former les
professionnels de santé de ce plan
c'était la compétence des régions elles
ne l'ont pas fait
notre plan alzheimer a eu beaucoup de
mal à se mettre en place quand on a dit
qu'on allait lutter contre le chômage ou
réformer la formation professionnelle il
aurait fallu que les régions sont avec
nous elles ne l'ont pas été et elles ont
du coup elles ont pesé sur la croissance
et sur l'emploi dans notre pays quand on
a fait le plan campus avec nicolas
sarkozy on a eu cinq milliards d'euros
sur les universités les régions
socialistes ont bloqué le plan campus
parce qu'il le fallait évidemment pas
que la droite s'intéresse à l'université
les régions ont un énorme pouvoir de
blocage
et donc si nous voulons vraiment
réformer la france eh bien il faut
absolument gagner les régions alors
depuis plus de dix ans vous le savez la
gauche contrôle presque tous les
conseils régionaux et son bilan on le
connaît il est accablant il tient en
quatre mots gabegie
impôts cliente élise chômage alors on
peut pas rester les bras ballants
on doit se lever on doit résister et on
doit gagner il faut refonder le pacte
régional sur nos valeurs être droit dans
nos valeurs celles des républicains
l'autorité la liberté et la justice mais
la justice la vraie pas celle de
l'assistanat
celle qui met en avant le travail le
mérite et l'effort
alors moi je crois que nous devons faire
de nos régions des régions conquérante
exemplaires et réconcilier conquérante
sur l'emploi en favorisant par tous les
moyens le travail dans nos régions et on
assume en de donner un vrai coup de
pouce à nos pme
comment est ce qu'on donne la préférence
à nos pme bas c'est très simple on
élabore des marchés publics de la
commande publique en mettant des clauses
qui permettent d'avoir des petites
entreprises qui répondent et la région
s'engagera à payer dès la réception la
facture pourquoi est ce qu'il faut faire
ça il faut faire ça parce que c'est les
pme qui vont créer l'emploi de demain
dans la france qui nous attend et cpa
mais aujourd'hui elles ne peuvent pas
avoir accès à la commande publique vous
donner un exemple les manuels scolaires
des lycées aujourd'hui quand les manuels
scolaires des lycées on demande de faire
appel à une très grande centrale d'achat
et on globalise les commandes
demain on pourrait très bien dire que
chaque lycée peut commander dans la
librairie de la ville ou dans les
librairies de la ville il ça voudrait
dire qu'on fait vivre toute issue
libraires indépendants voilà comment il
faut fonctionner il faut donner la
préférence aux pme dans la commande
publique
et puis il faut aussi donner la priorité
aux produits locale comment est ce qu'on
donne la priorité aux produits locale en
respectant les règles des marchés
publics
et bien tout simplement en mettant un
certain nombre de conditions de service
après-vente de maintenance si vous dites
à bas ces travaux si jamais il ya un
problème ou un souci il faudra réparer
maintenir dans les 24 heures ça veut
dire que les seules sociétés et les
entreprises qui pourront candidater à la
commande publique sont des entreprises
qui ont des salariés en france et pas
des entreprises étrangères qui viendront
en dames ping fiscale en dom ping
environnementale en 2 min social prendre
les marchés casser les prix et qui le
lendemain auront disparu et quand on
s'aperçoit que les produits qu'ils ont
livrés sont des produits de mauvaise
qualité il ya plus personne
on a tué notre tissu de pme et à côté de
ça eh ben on peut plus entretenir nos
équipements alors voilà la priorité aux
produits local c'est possible dans le
respect des règles de marchés publics et
puis on va parler un petit peu des
cantines c'est scandaleux d'avoir
aujourd'hui de la viande uruguayenne et
les pommes chinoise il faut évidemment
qu'on fasse marcher les producteurs
locaux
c'est possible avec la loi le maire qui
parle de s'approvisionner en circuits
courts c'est possible sauf que le
gouvernement n'a jamais clarifié la
responsabilité des élus dans ce domaine
nous demandons au gouvernement de
clarifier la responsabilité des
présidents de région pour que dans les
cantines des lycées on puisse servir des
produits locaux
alors je voudrais aussi parler un peu de
la version de la courbe du chômage parce
que alors que nous connaissons un
chômage record qui est indigne de la
france
il est intolérable que moins d'un
chômeur sur dix est droit à une
formation régionale
la formation c'est la compétence des
régions moi je vous le dis en ile de
france
nous avons cent mille emplois non
pourvus et 660 mille chômeurs alors le
sujet c'est de doubler l'effort de
formation pour offrir 100 mille
formation pour ses cent mille emplois
dans lesquels nous n'avons pas de
personnel qualifié
ils savent à de l'informatique à la
fibre optique au numérique jusqu aux
emplois de services à la personne et aux
emplois de santé les régions les régions
doivent aussi être conquérante avec la
jeunesse s'il ya une promesse de
françois hollande qui n'a pas été tenu
sa promesse vis-à-vis de la jeunesse
eh bien nous nous devons relever le gant
je ferai tout pour la réussite des
jeunes avec des solutions très concrètes
les stages quand les jeunes n'ont pas de
carnet l'adresse quand ils n'ont pas de
piston comment faire pour avoir le
premier stage celui qui leur garantit
d'aller dans leur formation en
alternance celui qui leur garantit de m
le premier pied sur le marché de
l'emploi
alors moi j'ai regardé et je me suis
aperçu que l'île de france donnait 2
milliards d'euros de subventions chaque
année 2 milliards d'euros de subventions
aux associations aux entreprises aux
collectivités aux établissements publics
eh bien j'ai décidé qu'on allait mettre
en place un principe subventions contre
l'accueil d'un jeune
vous voulez une subvention de la région
à chaque fois qu'on vous donne vingt
mille euros
vous contrôlez un jeune en stage de deux
mois en contrat d'apprentissage en
contrat d'insertion mission locale peu
importe
l'objectif c'est de donner un grand coup
des pôles dans la porte de l'emploi et
de permettre à nos jeunes d'y mettre les
pieds
voilà ce que nous allons faire
concrètement pour les jeunes c'est une
contrepartie civique que nous demandons
aux organismes subventionnés par la
région
pareil on a un problème aujourd'hui
c'est que beaucoup d'emplois ne sont pas
pourvus parce que les jeunes ne passe
plus le permis de conduire
et qu' ils ne peuvent pas se rendre dans
les entreprises qui pourraient les
accueillir alors moi j'ai proposé que la
région finance le code de la route
gratuit pour tous les jeunes en cfa en
lice est en mission locale comment on va
faire où est ce qu'on va trouver
l'argent
eh bien j'ai été regardé ce qui se
faisait à l'étranger j'ai été regardé en
suisse en belgique en autriche en
allemagne en grande-bretagne
il vante les numéros des plaques
minéralogiques
ils les vendent à ceux qui veulent les
acheter à ceux qui veulent mettre leurs
initiales à ceux qui veulent mettre un
message
alors évidemment on va pouvoir faire ça
en france parce que la ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'appelle bernard
cazeneuve qui est de gauche et qui va me
dire un an mais c'est pas possible via
un logiciel du mr l'intérieur on peut
pas y toucher on peut rien faire donc
comme je sais que je pourrai pas vendre
les numéros j'ai réfléchi
vous savez que sur les plaques
minéralogiques un petit cartouches avec
le logo de la région et le numéro du
département de votre choix
les mêmes droits de rien m eh ben je
vais proposer miss à l'intérieur de
vendre ces petits cartouches et de les
personnaliser avec le logo de votre
entreprise avec jp r avec les
républicains avec ce qu'on veut
il ya des millions de véhicules qui sont
mis qui sont mis en circulation chaque
année on peut gagner de quoi nourrir un
fonds social pour l'apprentissage qui
codent gratuit pour tous les jeunes de
france alors pareil sur les emplois
jeunes c'est sympathique les emplois
jeunes
mais moi les 15000 emplois jeunes de ma
région 1 ils sont plus en association
demain après-demain ils sont dans les
tpe pour les aider à grandir à faire du
chiffre d'affaires et pour donner à ces
jeunes un emploi durable
enfin je crois que nous avons un message
très important a adressé à la jeunesse
et ce message c'est celui de la
reconnaissance du travail du mérite et
de l'effort et vous savez que avec tous
nos collègues bruno retailleau laurent
wauquiez tous les autres nous avons
décidé de rétablir les bourses au mérite
pour les bacheliers mention très bien
des favorisés parce que c'est scandaleux
c'est scandaleux que des jeunes
dealer à 15 ans gagne 1000 euros par
mois et que madame najat vallaud
belkacem 10 aux bacheliers mention très
bien on n'a pas l'argent pour vous
donner 200 euros de bourse
supplémentaire
c'est indigne on sait bien que ces
jeunes bacheliers mention très bien ils
sont des modèles
c'est la fierté de leur quartier c'est
la fierté de leur lycée c'est la fierté
de leur famille
cd anti modèle pour tous ces jeunes qui
vivent des trafics et nous on doit dire
que la république leur est
reconnaissante
on doit dire qu'ils sont aussi la fierté
de nos régions
alors nos régions elles doivent être
aussi exemplaire il faut en finir avec
la dérive financière des régions
socialistes qui a fait exploser la dette
et les impôts
une région exemplaire c'est d'abord une
région qui comme je le propose met fin
au train de vie luxueux de la gauche
pour financer vraiment les priorités des
français sans aucune augmentation
d'impôts
vous savez qu en ile-de-france on habite
dans cinq hôtels particuliers et qu'il
faut louer en plus 26 millions d'euros
de d'immeubles pour m les agents de la
région et bien moi je les dis je les dis
à mes adversaires
nous on est élu on déménage on déménage
de l'autre côté du périphérique et on
vous rend l'argent alors je dois avouer
que je suis un peu seul sur cette
proposition parce que comme vous le
savez nous en ile de france on a une
gauche qui n'aime pas les riches mais
qui aime bien vivre avec
une région exemplaire c'est aussi une
région qui sera intraitable sur
l'éthique et les valeurs de la
république
ma ligne de conduite à l'éclair pas de
subventions régionales pour ceux qui
bafouent les valeurs de la république et
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que on arrête
l'encouragement à l'immigration illégale
en ile de france on a voté une
délibération qui s'appelle réfugiés
slash migrants dans laquelle le conseil
régional mélange la situation des
réfugiés politiques des réfugiés de
guerre que nous devons accueillir parce
que c'est notre devoir d'humanité avec
celle des migrants économiques illégaux
elle les mélanges
elle leur donne un droit prioritaire au
logement social régional avant les
franciliens qui en attendent un depuis
des années c'est absurde
nous devons avoir le courage de dire
qu'il ya deux situations très
différentes
la situation des réfugiés et la
situation des illégaux les illégaux nous
n'avons pas les moyens de les accueillir
de leur donner un travail de les loger
et de les intégrer les illégaux prenons
manuel valls homos ils ont vocation à
rentrer chez eux
alors comment comment ça se traduit et
bien c'est simple si je suis présidente
de région
je supprimerai la réduction de 75% dont
bénéficient les étrangers en situation
irrégulière dans les transports 70
millions de manque à gagner haut la ratp
la sncf une région exemplaire c'est
enfin une région qui saura vous protéger
il faut mettre en place de vrais bulle
de sécurité autour des lycées j'y
reviendrai mais je propose d'aller
encore plus loin sur ces sujets de
sécurité
il y à un sujet qui est majeur nous
devons rénover tous les trains et tous
les transports de france
vous vous souvenez du tragique accident
brétigny qui a coûté calendrier limoges
et bien l'accident de retinne il a eu
lieu sur des lignes franciliennes qui
était totalement vitus alors si on veut
avoir le moyen de faire ces rénovations
de ligne sur la sncf et la ratp
il ya un moyen de le financer c'est de
lutter fermement enfin contre la fraude
dans les transports la fraude dans les
transports dans toute la france c'est
500 millions d'euros de manque à gagner
pour les sociétés de transport alors il
ya une seule mesure efficace qui
demandait par la sncf qui refusaient par
le gouvernement c'est d'imposer le port
de papiers d'identité quand on prend les
transports en commun est de donner aux
contrôleurs la possibilité de demander
le l'identité des fraudeurs aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe les fraudeurs
donne des faux noms les fausses adresses
donc vous avez que 5% des amendes sncf
qui sont payés 5% alors que pour les
automobilistes c'est 80 % parce qu'on a
le permis de conduire et la plaque
d'immatriculation
il faut mettre fin à ce scandale nous
ont dit non à la fraude parce qu'elle
est totalement injuste pour ceux qui
payent
et puis il ya les pickpockets et les
voleurs toujours dans les transports est
ce que vous savez que aujourd'hui paris
est considérée par les chinois cher jean
pierre comme une des villes touristiques
les moins sûres du monde
est ce que vous savez que les tour
opérateurs chinois font venir des gardes
du corps en civil pour protéger les
touristes chinois dans paris est ce que
c'est normal est-ce que c'est digne de
nous alors moi je vais faire une
proposition iconoclaste encore une
je propose que pour les pickpockets
multirécidiviste que tout le monde
connaît qui commettent ni l'acte en
moyenne par an mil actes en moyenne par
an 1000 vols à l'arraché par an je
propose que pour ces multirécidivistes
il puisse y avoir une peine
complémentaire d'interdiction des
réseaux de transport comme ya eu une
peine d'interdiction de stade pour les
supporters violents des matchs de foot
enfin nos régions doivent être
réconciliées réconcilier est au coeur de
cette réconciliation il y a les familles
les familles qui ont été matraquées par
le gouvernement de françois hollande
à tel point d'ailleurs que vous avez vu
le résultat taux de natalité baisse
on ne saurait mieux dire on a un
gouvernement qui n'a cessé d'attaquer
les famines
elle a obtenu le gouvernement a obtenu
le résultat qu'elle voulait qu'il
voulait eh bien nous nous allons faire
tout le contraire
votre politique régionale sera une
politique familiale avec la liberté de
choisir l'école de ses enfants garantie
avec des crèches avec des cantines moins
cher la gauche francilienne à supprimer
la gratuité des manuels scolaires et les
aides à la cantine et les ailes d'un
investissement dans les lycées privés en
arguant d'une vision absurde de la
laïcité
nous ce que nous pensons c'est que
toutes les familles même les familles
les plus modestes ont le droit de
choisir l'école de leurs enfants
alors j'ai un dernier combat que je veux
engager
c'est le combat contre la drogue parce
que c' est l' angoisse de tous les
parents de voir ses enfants tomber là
dedans et c'est une source et on le sait
de démotivation et d'échec scolaire
alors moi je refuse qu'on ferme les yeux
et qu'on baisse la tête
je refuse de voir des supermarchés de la
drogue aux portes de nos lycées
alors c'est pour cela que j'ai proposé
que la région ile de france puissent
financer avec l'accord des conseils
d'administration des lycées bien
évidemment et dans le respect du secret
médical des tests de dépistage
systématique auprès des enfants pour
qu'on prenne enfin le problème à bras le
corps et qu'on combatte sérieusement ce
fléau qui est un drame pour toutes les
familles et puis j'ai proposé un plan de
lutte contre les dealers pour que vous
abordez lycée on ne trouve plus c'est ce
fléau de la drogue
voilà alors j'avais envie de vous dire
plein d'autres choses sur comment on
casserait les ghettos urbains et sur
comment on aiderait
les territoires ruraux mais je sais que
mon temps est passé alors ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que dès le mois
prochain
nous pouvons et nous allons changer les
choses
malraux disait que les grands rêves
conduisent aux grandes actions et parce
que nous allons nous avons de grands
rêves
nous allons agir pour nos régions il
nous reste un mois un mois pour
convaincre
moi je vous le dit l'alternance est en
marche
rien ne l'arrêtera je compte sur vous en
avant